as many of you are familiar less perhaps
here in Southern California certainly
those in Northern California the largest
investor owned utility in the state of
California PG&E has been advancing
significant power shutoffs what we refer
to commonly as PSPs Public Safety power
shut offs blackouts perhaps vernacular
others number a week or so ago close to
two million individuals were impacted by
those power shutdowns today we have
roughly a hundred and seventy eight
thousand customers that have been
impacted by now the latest power shut
offs not immune from power shut offs but
then again not necessarily surprised by
them either here in Southern California
particularly in San Diego that has
advanced similar strategies now for over
a decade
people are being impacted beginning here
in the seven County area that is under
Edison's jurisdiction we anticipate in
the extreme this has not yet happened
the prospect of some three hundred and
eight thousand customers being impacted
currently I believe it's roughly fifteen
thousand if that is correct in San Diego
a universe of roughly forty one thousand
customers again in the extreme are
potentially going to be impacted by
power setoffs roughly three thousand
currently so let me give you that again
so folks can understand the magnitude on
the high end of what potentially can be
anticipated three hundred eight thousand
in Edison's jurisdiction forty-one
thousand customers in San Diego Gas and
electrics jurisdiction and a hundred and
seventy eight thousand already impacted
in P Jeannie's jurisdiction we have what